Florida governor
Ron DeSantis,
who is an expected
20, 24 presidential hopeful,
is breaking his silence on Trump's
legal troubles
and the looming indictment.
DeSantis calling
the Manhattan
District Attorney's investigation
politically motivated
and vowing
that his office won't get involved
if the matter reaches his state,
though it's not expected to.
At the same time, though,
he made a point of highlighting
the conduct
at the heart of the investigation
I don't know what goes into
paying hush money to a porn star
to to secure silence
over some type of alleged affair.
I just I can't speak to that
but what I can speak to
is that if you have a prosecutor
who is ignoring crimes happening
every single day in his jurisdiction,
and he chooses to go back
many, many years ago
to try to use something about
porn star hush money payments,
you know, that's an example
of pursuing
a political agenda
and weaponizing the office.
So, you know,
he was getting asked
that question by a reporter,
but he had been facing
some pressure from Trump's allies.
Why haven't you said anything about this?
Because we saw a lot of other Republicans
weighing in as soon as on Saturday.
And DeSantis in Orlando yesterday.
But but notable, you know,
he got criticized by Donald Trump Jr
who said he thought he was minimizing it.
And his response
is a little shady, right.
When he didn't have to point out.
Did not have to point the heart of this?
The obvious.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, House Republicans
trying to intervene to defend,
you know, head of this Donald Trump,
a possible indictment here of House
Judiciary Chairman
Jim Jordan
and two other committee chairs
are demanding testimony
from Manhattan's justice attorney.
It's an extraordinary move
because Alvin Bragg doesn't work
for the federal government.
He's a local prosecutor
and this isn't a federal case.
In a letter,
the chairman accuse Bragg
of unprecedented abuse of prosecute
prosecutors moral authority.
Congressman Jim
Jordan admits that he doesn't
actually know the full
scope of potential charges.
But you don't know
the charges against him
on what you guys have told us.
That's all been jumping to conclusions
because he may have broken the law
as a concern.
We don't think
and we don't think
President Trump broke the law at all.
But what concerns me
is what they're going to do based on
what's been reported by Southwest.
Yeah, it's interesting
that they're making all of these comments
and they don't even know
what's going to happen
if there's even going to be
an indictment.
So that's why we turn to CNN's
Melanie's are known to live in Orlando
where House Republicans
are having their annual retreat.
So I'm sure she's got information
on that.
Good morning to you, Melanie.
What's the latest
Good morning to you, Don,
from chilly Orlando.
But House Republicans
are turning up the heat on the Manhattan
district attorney's office
ahead of a possible Trump indictment.
Three committee chairmen yesterday
fired off a letter to Alvin Bragg.
They are seeking both documents
and his testimony by March.
23rd.
They want to know
whether federal funds were used
to investigate
Donald Trump over this hush money
payment to Stormy Daniels.
And they also want to know
whether there was any communication
between the Manhattan D.A.
office
and between the Department of Justice.
I want to read you part of the letter
where they explained
some of their reasoning.
They wrote, Your decision to pursue
such a
politically motivated prosecution
that requires
congressional scrutiny
about how public safety funds
appropriated by Congress
are implemented
by local law enforcement agencies.
Now, Republicans admit
they don't have any knowledge
of whether federal funds
are actually used
in these sorts of cases.
And they also admit
they don't know
the full scope of the charges
that Trump might be facing.
So it really shows
the extraordinary lengths
that House
Republicans are willing to go
to defend Trump
and to try to discredit
this investigation.
Is pressing brag
something the entire GOP agrees on here?
I mean, could they be jumping the gun
since they don't know?
As I said,
they don't know
if charges will even be filed.
Melanie
Right, Don, we've actually been asking
that request,
that exact question to Republicans
here at their policy retreat.
So far,
I've only talked to one Republican,
Don Bacon,
who represents a Biden district
who said it would be more
appropriate to wait
until they see the actual indictment.
But most Republicans
are defending this effort
to intervene in an ongoing
criminal probe.
Again, a very extraordinary
and unprecedented move.
Speaker Kevin McCarthy in a pen
and pad with reporters yesterday
said they have a right to ask questions.
Scott Perry, the chairman of the House
Freedom Caucus, told me
they don't need to wait
because they see the writing
on the wall here.
But Democrats
see this as an abuse of power,
a waste of congressional resources
and the Manhattan
District Attorney's Office
said they will not be intimidated
by any effort to interfere
in the justice system. Don.